une fois n'est pas coutume je vous
propose tout de suite un second débat
lié à l'actualité du jour avec la grève
des salariés d'edf 37 % de grévistes qui
protestent contre la décision du
gouvernement de plafonner les prix et
surtout d'augmenter le volume
d'électricité vendus à prix réduit aux
concurrents jeremy greenspan
une banderole pour exprimer leur colère
ce matin devant la centrale de
gravelines dans le nord ces employés
d'edf manifester contre les décisions du
gouvernement nous on est très inquiet
pour l'avenir puisqu'on a pu assister à
une décote en bourse importante du titre
edf mais également de sa baisse en terme
de notation l'action de l'entreprise est
en chute libre depuis les annonces de
bercy il ya deux semaines qui selon ses
salariés contraignent edf à brader son
électricité pour tenir sa promesse de
limiter à 4% la hausse des tarifs en
2022 l'exécutif demande à edf
d'augmenter sa part de production
destinée à ses concurrents tout en la
vendant à prix réduit une mesure qui
coûterait environ 8 milliards d'euros à
l'entreprise mais toujours assumé par
l'état actionnaire à 84 % d'edf l'état
et c'est surprenant actionnaire
majoritaire donc je pense que c'est
légitime que nous demandions à edf un
effort quand on estime que c'est
l'intérêt général qui est en jeu il n'y
a pas de raison de s'inquiéter pour
l'avenir d'edf jeu rappelait aussi
l'engagement du président la république
du gouvernement à relancer le programme
nucléaire dans notre pays pourtant la
décision a fait réagir jusqu'au
directeur d'edf qui la qualifie de
véritable choc pour l'entreprise de leur
côté les syndicats assurent que les
consommateurs devront quand même payer
la facture tôt ou tard c'est un artifice
qui était mis en oeuvre à des buts
purement électoraliste pour venir gommer
le
neos d'électricité le temps d'une
campagne présidentielle en fait on est
sur une pente
d'augmentation la contractualisation sur
sur le marché même pour les années 2000
23 2024 elle est déjà hôte donc on sait
que l'augmentation pour pour les usagers
elle va durer dans le temps pour
remédier à la situation
il demande à l'état de mettre fin à la
logique de marché et de baisser la tva
sur l'électricité
edf at-elle été sacrifiés voilà le thème
de notre débat et je vous présente mes
invités dominique estrosi sassone mon
soir bonsoir cette sénatrice l ère des
alpes-maritimes vice présidente de la
commission des affaires économiques au
sénat bénédicte pérol bonsoir vous êtes
député elles mêmes la république en
marge de l'allier françois lévêque
bonsoir soit professeur d'économie à
l'école des mines de paris et auteur de
nucléaire on off analyse économique d'un
pari c'est publié chez dunod matthieu
croissandeau toujours à mes côtés
évidemment peut-être une réaction un peu
général pour commencer dominique estrosi
sassone qu'est ce que vous pensez de la
la décision du gouvernement prise on va
dire pour faire face à une urgence en
tout cas c'est comme ça oui en tous cas
prises pour protéger le pouvoir d'achat
des français à quelques semaines de
l'élection présidentielle
je regrette que le gouvernement n'ait
pas anticipé cette flambée des prix des
énergies alors on parle de l'électricité
mais il ya eu aussi le gaz les
carburants et les combustibles ont pour
elles et même au delà en parlant des
matières premières donc il y avait de
quoi anticiper parce que de nombreux
économistes avaient prédit cette flambée
des prix d'énergie au sortir de la crise
qu vie de 19 et donc finalement on voit
que le gouvernement n'ayant pas anticipé
prend une mesure qui est une mesure
purement conjoncturelle qui est une
mesure de court terme qui me semble peu
évaluées et mal calibré et finalement je
pense que il aurait mieux valu prendre
des mesures qui soient des mesures
beaucoup plus structurelle alors on y
reviendra pas parce qu'ils ont anticipé
pour faire quoi ce sera une des
questions je poserai évidemment tout à
l'heure bennink pérols et une mesure
d'urgence
qu'est ce que vous répondez à cette
critique sur le manque d'anticipation du
alors il ya effectivement un état de
fait qui date déjà depuis la fin d'année
dernière et même à la sortie de l'été ou
à une augmentation des prix
d'électricité due à plusieurs facteurs
l'augmentation du prix du gaz du fait
géopolitique notamment il est à
l'augmentation des prix du carbone aussi
sur le marché européen et puis il ya
aussi la production d'électricité
nucléaire qui est en 2021 moins
importante et aux réductions permanentes
et tout ça parce qu'on a beaucoup de
deux réacteurs en révision notamment
mais tout ça fait qu'il ait une
augmentation des prix très importantes
et c'est une crise mondiale et une crise
européenne aussi en particulier il faut
le dire et la constitution des prix de
l'électricité vous le savez est là aussi
on l'a beaucoup critiquée et là ce sera
des réformes structurelles mais sur le
marché européen sont fixés en fonction
notamment du prix du gaz est donc tout
ça on le savait déjà encore une fois la
sortie de l'été on a annoncé à la fin de
l'année et c'était dans le projet de loi
de finances pour 2022 une limitation des
prix l'électricité à 4% dans un premier
temps on a pris des mesures notamment de
réduction de la taxe d'une des taxes sur
l'électricité qui est une une mesure qui
coûte plus de 8 milliards d'euros à
l'état et c'est vrai qu'en ce début
d'année et une augmentation fulgurante
de ces prix encore de l'électricité on
ne sait pas si ça va perdurer peut-être
que ça va ça va effectivement perdurer
et l'état se devait de tenir son
engagement de limiter à 4% d'où cette
négociation avec edf et d'où ce choix
qui a été fait effectivement par le
gouvernement alors françois électio sur
cette idée d'anticipation est ce qu'on
pouvait et qu'est-ce qu'on pouvait
anticiper à ce qu'on peut anticiper
c'est que la tendance est à
l'augmentation des prix de l'énergie
tous vecteurs confondues sur les 5 10 15
20 prochaines années donc ça on peut
l'anticipent vrai pourquoi parce que il
ya un truc qui s'appelle la
décarbonation sa voix là et ça ça va
coûter de l'argent de faire ces
changements technologiques de se passer
du charbon de se passer du pétrole ou en
tout cas dans qu'on sait moins on va y
avoir une électrification massy et donc
voilà la tendance
l'énergie ça on le sait un peu l'anti se
perd en revanche il ya un truc ça va
être des chemins notre truc les chocs
g-shock de prix et donc là on a un choc
de prix et par définition les chocs sont
quand même beaucoup plus difficile à
anticiper donc il ya longtemps il ya eu
les chocs pétroliers là on a un choc de
prix sur le gaz sont un choc de prix qui
se du coup ce transfert sur
l'électricité on a un choc de prix sur
le pétrole noc les chocs c'est un peu
différent et notamment en termes de
politiques publiques on peut concevoir
que lorsqu'il ya des chocs et bien il y
à une intervention publique pourquoi
parce qu' il peut y avoir des ménages il
peut y avoir des entreprises qui ne vont
pas résisté au choc et dans ce cas là
est bien une entreprise qui est rentable
et efficace qui ne résiste pas aux chocs
et qui ferment et bien c'est dommage
parce que c'est une perte pour la
collectivité parce qu'elle aurait voilà
le choc après et bien à six mois après
un an après l'entreprise et du
gouvernement dit avec chiffrent à 150
entreprises qui auraient pu mettre la
clé sous la porte sans cette attention
il ya des justifications économiques
lorsqu'il ya un choc y compris pour les
ménages qui sont noirs la question
seront plus sont plus de l'ordre de la
de l'éthique il ya des morts il ya des
ménages voilà qui peuvent pas subir un
choc de prix faramineux de hausse de
l'énergie et parce que ce sont les
ménages précaires donc voilà mais en
tout cas quand il ya un choc et là c'est
ce que je regrette sur 7 les mesures qui
sont prises quand il ya un choc on va
cibler on va cibler les entreprises
fragiles on va cibler les ménages
fragiles ont fait pas à
tous azimuts parce que en effet nos
veines pour certaines entreprises
notamment voilà parce que d'une part ça
coûte de l'argent vont intervenir et à
qui ça coûte de l'argent de faire ça et
en tout cas il y à des entreprises qui
peuvent parfaitement résister aux chocs
et des ménages qui peuvent résister aux
chocs j'ai pas honte de dire que je suis
capable de résister à un choc du prix de
l'électricité avec une augmentation de
40% y compris pour ma résidence
secondaire et je suis pas le seul dans
ce cas là il ya des ménages qui peuvent
pas voilà et donc il ya des entreprises
électro intensives qui peuvent pas
résister aux chocs et donc il faut aider
ces entreprises et incompris et pas
d'autres alors anticipé mais pour faire
quoi dominique estrosi sassone non mais
je veux c'est facile de dire ça mais
juste revenir sur ce que vient de dire
madame la députée
deal et à entamer une négociation avec
edf je pense pas qu'ils usent de
véritables négociations en voir la
réaction du président d'edf qui a quand
même parlé d'un véritable choc et qu'il
avait l'air de découvrir en tout cas
qu'il n'était pas d'accord avec cette
mesure qui lui a été imposée à travers
le fait qu'il fallait qu'ils cassent les
prix pour vendre de l'électricité pas
chers concurrents pas d'accord et des
faits pas d'accord avec le gouvernement
sur le bilan de cette mesure où ce que
ça va coûter à edf le départ d'un coût
de 7 à 8 milliards d'euros le
gouvernement dit plutôt 3 milliards
d'euros oui ça on verra pas ce que je
pense que 8 milliards d'euros estimés ou
évaluée par edf c'est sur le prix du
démarche est sûre en ce moment alors
c'est vrai que je pense qu'il faut aussi
attendre les résultats financier d'edf
qui vont être annoncées il ya peu une
négociation s'était imposé il n'y a pas
une mais je reviens la question qu'est
ce qu'on fait de mieux
mais je pense qu'il fallait prendre des
mesures structurelles parce que cette
mesure est une mesure à court terme
c'est une mesure comme l'a dit monsieur
le professeur qui est une mesure
générale qui ne cible pas spécifiquement
les entreprises les professionnels les
consommateurs qui peuvent être les plus
en difficulté et de toute façon cette
mesure elle pèsera sur l'ensemble des
fournisseurs d'énergie et elle se
répercutera sur des consommateurs qu'il
s'agisse des particuliers ou des
professionnels en 2023 bon allez un mode
réponse puis après on va rentrer un peu
dans le détail et l'avenir de 2d parce
que finalement la critique principale
qui vous est faite sur ce plateau où une
mère général c voilà c'est une mesure
électoraliste et si elle est passible et
c'est peut-être justement parce qu'elle
est électoraliste qu'est ce que vous
répondez à ça à toutes les décisions
qu'on prend ce moment de toute façon
sont et les taulards électoraliste
permanent et tous les déplacements font
faisceau aussi électorat linke
je me sens crient pas c'est clair dans
cet objectif là on répond à une urgence
il ya des réponses urgentes qu'on doit
apporter aux français donc je crois que
c'est se demande d'ailleurs ce qu'on
écoute dans l'hémicycle moi je trouve ça
c'est drôle de vous entendre dire il
faut des réformes structurelles sauf que
les réformes structurelles c'est très
très long si on prend la structuration
des prix l'énergie par exemple sur le
marché européen ça va demander des
négociations pas de quelques mois mais
de quelques années donc ça c'est
nécessaire de le faire néanmoins il y
avait des réponses d'urgence à apporter
sur peut-être la critique qui peut être
fait sur les mesures ciblées versus les
mesures générales
il ya aussi le pragmatisme politique et
l'état de fait du pays qui est la
bureaucratie qu'on connaît tous très
très bien qui fait que parfois on fait
un arbitrage effectivement entre des
mesures
ciblées mais qui aurait été très
complexe à mettre en oeuvre les plans de
l'usiné yeux je pense notamment aux
effectivement compte annoncer le chèque
l'inflation alors pour le goûter une
mesure très général à l'époque je sais
pas si vous vous souvenez mais déjà sur
les plateaux de télévisions réfléchit
c'est un chèque très ciblés concernant
les ménages effectivement peut-être
ruralité etc je rappelle juste l'usiné à
gaz mais pour le coup elle était très
élaborée de la taxe carbone et la
redistribution qui avait été imaginé
sous nicolas sarkozy qui était mais dans
l'intuition et dans l'intention très
très bonne mais c'était une véritable
usine à gaz et on nous aurait fait le
reproche de l' usine à gaz dont on a
fait un arbitrage politique aujourd'hui
ce n'est pas parfait
néanmoins moi je défends bien évidemment
ces choix là parce que je crois que il
apporte une réponse et une réponse qui
nous permettait d'être réactif et ce qui
est intéressant mathieu c'est que c'est
vrai pour le chèque inflation sans doute
aussi c'est que à peine octroyé déjà
oublié d'une certaine façon dont les
pinots donc l'effet électorale il est
peut-être l'effet de l'électoral sera
faible parce que les gens quand on leur
quand on leur donne des chèques pour
leur donne des aides pour compenser
l'inflation
l'encaissé puis ensuite ils vont par
remercier le public doit avoir donné
c'est dire que c'est pas assez voilà et
généralement ils disent que c'est pas
assez c'est comme les hausses d'impôts
des baisses d'impôts baisser d imposer
jamais remercié parce que on se souvient
toujours quand il augmenter mais jamais
quand ils ont baissé moi ce qui me
frappe rem dans cette affaire c'est vrai
que c'est une réponse générale et dès
qu'on commence à finasser en disant on
va aider telle ou telle population on a
des effets de seuil en à télé des
problèmes de jean qu'isabelle pourquoi
lui et pourquoi pas moi mais on a quand
même là une réponse ce qui est
ponctuelle à une situation qui peut
perdurer et qui va se peut s'étendre à
d'autres secteurs je vous donne un
exemple il ya trois jours l'association
familles de france a mis rural réclamer
un chèque fruits et légumes parce que le
prix des fruits et légumes avaient
considérablement augmenté donc est-ce
qu'on va être obligé ici et là
d'éteindre le feu avec ici un chèque ici
une subvention ici une indemnité moi je
m'interroge sur la notion de blocage des
prix c'est prévu par le code du commerce
quand même le blocage des prix ça ne
peut se faire dans des circonstances
exceptionnelles ça a été fait pendant la
guerre du golfe ou sonner sur les
carburants ça a été fait pendant la
crise qu vide sur le prix du gel hydro
alcoolique est pourquoi c'est pas une
option que vous que vous avez envisagé
que ce soit sur l'électricité ou
carburant
elle fait partie encore une fois des
palettes d'outils qui sont disponibles
dans les choix politiques qui sont faits
alors je ne suis pas dans les
négociations vont être déterminantes
deux tiers sont derrière
enfin ben là c'est un blocage lycéens
bloquent notamment ceva gel des prix du
gaz
35 % et 44 68 il ya un tarif qui
s'appelle le tarif bleu un tarif qui est
fixé par les pouvoirs publics mittal du
gouvernement a dit qu on augmenterait
pas le tarif malgré la méthode de calcul
qui est mise au point que plus alors je
vais avancer le débat autour de pardon
d'intérêt autour de l'avenir d'edf avec
maintien ce chiffre là la dette d'edf
aujourd'hui on est à plus de 42
milliards d'euros
42,3 milliards d'euros et quand on voit
ce chiffre on n'est pas surpris par la
réaction d'eric zemmour ce matin sur
public sénat face à aurillac mansigné
aux journalistes de la presse régionale
on les écoute vous savez c'est très
grave ce qui est en train de se passer
car le gouvernement pour des raisons
démagogiques est en train de tuer edf
c'est très important pour expliquer aux
gens ce qui se passe et comment on n'est
pas en train de bavarder à le legs de dd
français et du général de gaulle alors
lointain de tuer edf l'accusation est
quand même très très lourde
est ce que ces 42 3 milliards de dettes
et puis ce qui va se rajouter là est-ce
que ça fragilise l'entreprise au point
qu'elle est en danger ce qui fragilise
les entreprises c'est quand elle a un
actionnaire qui l'amène à hue et à dia
c'est quand vous avez un actionnaire qui
à certains moments demande investi
appuyé le même actionnaire un an plus
tard va demander de ne pas augmenter ses
prix même si les coûts augmentent et
puis plus tard va demander peut-être de
développer l'emploi donc quand vous avez
un actionnaire qui changent l'objectif
de l'entreprise tous les six mois c'est
très compliqué et ça c'est pas
simplement ce gouvernement c'est
malheureusement assez historique que
l'actionnaire public et donc une
entreprise qui n'a pas qui ne peut pas
mener ses objectifs parce que les
objectifs changent tout le temps c'est
un peu compliqué
attendons aussi enfin remarquons que il
ya un absent ici il s'appelle le
contribuable l'état alors on parlait
l'état il n'est pas en train de créer de
l'argent pour le distribuer aux
consommateurs l'état il reçoit de
l'argent et quand l'état décide de
réduire cet axe eh bien ça fait moins
d'argent et donc c'est le contribuable
qui un jour ou qui un jour ou l'autre à
payer je vous rappelle que si nous
sommes tous actionnaires d'edf
d'enseignants entreprises et tous
contribuables sur ce plateau aussi
actionnaire si si edf perd et se sont
retrouvés pour finir archers et bien et
bien en tant qu'actionnaire nous perdons
d'un champ quand actionnaires quand edf
dépérit si l'effet des péris et bien
c'est nous qui sommes en train de
dépérir comme actionnaire quand mark
zuckenberg
voilà la valeur de facebook s'effondrer
se bat c'est lui qui sait lui qui
inquiète à moins de qui a moins de
revenus et que c'est lui qui s'appauvrit
un camp edf son cours des cent et bien
c'est nous qui nous appauvrissons donc
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire dominique
estrosi sassone il faut donner de la vie
habilité à cette entreprise publique
françois lui disait finalement son
actionnaire principal l'état ses 84 % de
l'actionnariat d'edf le le maine le tire
à hue et à dia
pourquoi il faut de la visibilité à
londres il faudrait d'abord commencer
par avoir une stratégie claire une
stratégie globale en matière de
politique énergétique
au delà de df ce qui n'a pas déplu que
le cad emmanuel macron depuis le début
de sa mandature faut quand même se
rappeler que en 2018 il annonce la
fermeture de fessenheim il annonce la
fermeture de 14 réacteurs nucléaires
d'ici 2035 et puis politique en zigzag
en novembre dernier novembre 2021 alors
là il reconnaît tous les bienfaits de
l'énergie nucléaire eh bien ça aussi ça
a participé cette absence de stratégie
cette politique de gribouille cette
politique en zigzag et bien le
conduisent aujourd'hui pour partie à la
situation dans laquelle se trouve edf à
travers les décisions prises par le
gouvernement emmanuel macron est rendu
coupable de cette situation parce que
l'impératif de sécuriser nos
approvisionnements énergétiques et bien
ça passe d'abord par cette stratégie qui
est une stratégie claire transparente
qui s'inscrit forcément dans le long
terme depuis 2017 et plus
particulièrement 2018 nous n'avons pas
du tout assisté à ce type de stratégie
mené en matière de politique énergétique
avec assumer qu'il faut qu'il y ait deux
jambes d'un côté nucléaire de l'autre
côté les énergies renouvelables il perd
c'est vrai que le président on peut le
dire a changé de pied sur le nucléaire
alors dire qu'il ya pas stratégie et une
programmation pluriannuelle de l'énergie
qui a été élaborée sous ce quinquennat
moi ce que je regrette c'est qu'elle
soit pas passé devant le parlement ce
sera le cas à l'occasion de la prochaine
ppe pour l'acronyme que nous utilisons
néanmoins il stratégie ya eu la revue de
la stratégie nationale bas carbone aussi
qui nous permet d'être la déclinaison de
est ce que oui ou non le président
s'était rangée finalement aux arguments
de
tenir les objectifs
de réduction notre notre empreinte
carbone on ne peut pas se passer d'une
prison la république n'a jamais été zéro
nucléaire train de dire dans la
programmation pluriannuelle de l'énergie
on est à 50% de nucléaire je ne dis pas
qu'aujourd'hui au regard des nouveaux
objectifs qu'on s'est fixés au regard du
green deal européen
finalement il est beaucoup beaucoup
d'évolutions ces trois dernières années
je ne dis pas qu'il ne faut pas revoir
la pp légalement les scénarios que nous
présente rte qui sont très très
intéressant de ce point de vue là moi je
ne crois pas aux héros nucléaire je
crois que le président ne croit pas aux
héros nucléaire et je crois que le
président donne une vision à aider f
quand il dit qu'il va on va devoir
produire un deuxième père quand il parle
aussi des small reactor qui sont une
technologie qui n'est pas totalement
aujourd'hui dont l'avenir certainement
sur la vision à très long terme
travaille on travaille en a
pas de vision il faut aussi investir
dans quelque chose qui est risqué c'est
l'objectif de semences 2030 et puis ya
une autre question qui se pose c'est
effectivement qu'est-ce qu'on fait ces
réacteurs aussi aujourd'hui on a
cinquante six réacteurs on sait qu'ils
ont une durée de vie
aujourd'hui qui au départ étaient trente
ans qu'on rallonge et du coup ça
nécessite des investissements
supplémentaires c'est vrai que la vraie
question qui doit être posée dès le
début du prochain quinquennat c'est
combien de réacteurs nucléaires
aujourd'hui on maintient est-ce qu'on
reste au à ce qu'on avait prévu dans la
programmation culturelle de l'énergie
est ce que on va un petit peu plus loin
ça c'est clair que c'est des questions
qu'il faut qu'on se pose très très vite
et moi j'aimerais que dès le début du
prochain quinquennat quelle que soit la
majorité en place cette programmation
elles soient revus avec une nouvelle
concertation en fonction ces nouveaux
éléments notamment européens dont nous
disposons aujourd'hui c'est vrai que
c'est un choix structurants pour les
prochaines décennies c'est un peu aussi
hama où ça redevient un marqueur
politique où ça l'était déjà
le nucléaire est surtout revenue à la
mode parce que c'était bien ça c'est
vrai qu'il ya cinq ans tout le monde
tout le monde disait il au fifo batum on
est beaucoup de gens beaucoup jour dans
la classe politique dit en tout cas
qu'il fallait à la fois fermer
fessenheim et réduire la part du
nucléaire dans notre production
d'électricité oui et développer les
énergies renouvelables
on s'appelle là il ya une sorte de
surenchère chez certains candidats je
suis le père qui seront ouvertes et bien
sûr bien sûr moi ce qui me frappe dans
le mouvement d'aujourd'hui c'est aussi
une forme de schizophrénie de la part
des salariés d'edf qui sont quand même
qu'ils nous ont vanté pendant des années
le fait qu'ils avaient un statut des
électriciens-gaziers du secteur public
qu'ils avaient une mission de service
public qui n'étaient pas des salariés
comme les autres et que tu auras et là
où l'état leur demande un effort au nom
de l'intérêt général est d'intérêt
public c'est leur casquette de salariés
actionnaires qui se dit attention on est
en train de plomber la boîte et on va
avoir enfin ils s'inquiètent pour
l'emploi il s'inquiète pour pour la
pérennité de l'entreprise je trouve
qu'on est aussi dans une forme de
schizophrénie c'est donc vous n'êtes pas
toujours d'accord avec christophe
castaner mais c'est à peu près ce qu'il
a ce qu'il a dit ce matin c'était sur
france 2 on écoute le président du
groupe la république en marche à
l'assemblée quand edf a connu des
difficultés l'état a toujours été
présent et quand aujourd'hui il ya des
moments donnés ou edf peut avoir des
difficultés l'etat sera toujours présent
pour koussa et la solidarité là j'avoue
que je ne comprends pas la logique de
dire j'ai un régime public spécifique
parce que je suis odf et je veux garder
le monopole par exemple sur les barrages
etc et je le défends et en même temps
dira mais attention quand il ya besoin
d'une action publique je veux pas y
penser quand vous avez la fierté d'être
dans une entreprise publique comme edf
vous assumez aussi de contribuer à la
solidarité nationale
37 % de grévistes aujourd'hui mais une
parole ils ont tort de faire grève je
veux pas dire qu'ils ont tort te faire
le droit de grève est constitutionnel
dans d'autres pays je ne vais pas dire
ça c'est vrai
lors de leur mission n'est pas si je
comprends que je ne comprends pas ce que
ce que je vois c'est qu'effectivement il
y à la fois les salariés qui défendent
l'entreprise qui ont peur pour l'avenir
de l'entreprise
on le sait tous éteints c'est un
patrimoine français très important mais
qui aujourd'hui à des difficultés
effectivement et l'etat sera là on le
dit mais néanmoins eu effectivement tant
que salarié ils ont ils en disent ont
des craintes pour leur entreprise et
c'est vrai qu'en tant que citoyen parce
que ce qu'on leur demande aujourd'hui
est ce qu'on peut dire ce que l'objectif
de cette politique publique qu'on mène
quand même de limiter la facture
d'électricité le français et des
entreprises et de préserver aussi notre
économie et donc préserver notre
économie c'est quoi c'est maintenir un
état qui seront en capacité de man aussi
de venir en soutien potentiellement de
cette entreprise et donc c est censé
mettre en place un cercle vertueux enfin
quand on nous dit ça ça va coûter demain
aux contribuables comme il savait si au
moment de la crise on s'était dit on va
mettre 100 milliards d'euros mais de
toute façon on va faire une différence
entre mettre de l'argent pour
l'investissement pour demain pour
développer des nouvelles technologies
pour l'éducation etc et là de la
redistribution c'est simplement un jeu
de redistribution c'est à dire que on
prend dans la poche le pôle pour mettre
dans la poche de chandhok les les
ménages consommateurs d'électricité sont
gagnants et les ménages contribuables
sont perdants alors si vous êtes un
ménage à haut revenu et que vous
consommez
peu d'électricité eh bien vous êtes
perdant si vous êtes un ménages à hauts
revenus vous consommez beaucoup
d'électricité ou à faible à faibles
impôts et vous consommez beaucoup
d'électricité et bien fenêtre voilà et
est donc on sait même pas qui on
identifie quelques gagnants et perdants
mais ne pas oublier et que certes il ya
les salariés d'edf il ya des
actionnaires et nous sommes actionnaires
tous d'edf il ya des contribuables et
puis il ya des consommateurs
d'électricité et tous les consommateurs
d'électricité sont ne contribue pas
forcément de la même façon aux impôts et
tous les contributeurs les contribuables
ne consomme pas de la même façon
d'électricité donc on a un truc
complètement confus on sait pas on sait
pas qui va gagner de l'argent et tu vas
perdre de l'âge mais il ya des gagnants
des perdants béni pérol non mais ça
s'efface et très juste je suis d'accord
avec cette cette analyse mais toute
façon quand on mène une politique
publique c'est toujours très très
compliqué effectivement et ce matin
d'ailleurs on a vu qu'on avait une
audition de l'insee devant la commission
des finances et c'est vrai quand on
demande d'entrer dans le détail des
gagnants des perdants de n'importe quel
dispositif qui est mis en place c'est
très très compliqué encore une fois je
redis on a fait un choix politique
effectivement entre des mesures ciblées
usine à gaz et ça je le regrette c'est à
dire je préférerais qu'on est un pays
beaucoup plus simples avec des
ministères qui collaborent dont on
partage les données les systèmes
d'information ce n'est pas le cas donc
qu'est ce qu'on fait on ment aux
français on leur dit oui on va faire des
mesures ciblées alors qu'on ne sait pas
faire ou alors on fait des mesures
générales alors effectivement qui coûte
très cher et il va falloir que entend
contribuables et en tant que français et
bien effectivement on participe demain
mais c'est le choix qu'on a fait
aujourd'hui et encore une fois on aurait
préféré ne pas faire de choix et que
tout allait bien dans le meilleur des
mondes or nos oppositions nous aurait
dit dans l'hémicycle vous ne faites rien
vous ne réagissez pas vous d'anticiper
pas les réformes structurelles a
effectivement madame pécresse nous
propose des réformes structurelles
néanmoins aujourd'hui les français si on
n'avait pas agi il aurait une
augmentation de la facture qui serait
exponentielle nous on souhaite limiter
pour les ménages à 30 euros
l'augmentation en 2022 des prix
l'électricité pour les entreprises à 60
euros ça aurait été plus de 300 euros
pour les ménages plus de 500 euros pour
les entreprises
si nous n'avions pas agi j'entends ça
mais
là on est vraiment sur une valeur vous
l'avez dit on peut avoir besoin d'une
intervention en cas de choc et c'est ça
peut être le rôle du gouvernement sauf
que on est parti pour combien de
décennies de prix élevés de
l'électricité
donc pendant combien de temps on va
pouvoir faire comme si le marché
n'existait pas vous voyez ce que je veux
dire et à maintenir des prix très bas
alors que partout ailleurs ça explose ça
c'est quand même un confortable d'autant
que c'est quand même une bonne nouvelle
pour l'environnement que les prix de
l'énergie augmentent parce que quand les
prix énergie augmentent eh bien il ya
quand même un effet sur la quantité
consommée vous consommez moins
d'électricité quand je le prie
électricité y compris les arguments les
carburants pardon donc de classer une
mauvaise nouvelle pour pour la planète
il faut habituer les consommateurs ça va
être compliqué habitué les consommateurs
les citoyens à faire face à un prix de
l'énergie a pris l'énergie élevé
donc la question qui se pose c'est la
question effectivement des
investissements qu'on doit qu'on doit
faire et que l'état doit faire pour edf
notamment vous avez évoqué l'état des
des centrales la dominique estrosi
sassone il avait le grand carénage c'est
stable le grand carénage c'est le fait
de maintenir en état ou de prolonger la
vie des centrales nucléaires donc là on
a plus de 42 milliards d'euros de dettes
on a cette mesure qui va coûter
plusieurs milliards d'euros à edf il
faut encore investir des dizaines de
milliards d'euros dans les prochaines
années pour maintenir le parc nucléaire
voir le faire grandir sur le credo de
nouveau de nouveaux acteurs donc là vous
nous dit on va à fond sur nucléaire mais
à quel prix oui mais donc ça montre bien
l'inquiétude
d'edf pour absorber quand même ce choc
financier passe qui non seulement il ya
la dette il ya 50 milliards d'euros pour
la rénovation pour des investissements
colossaux en matière de une parc
nucléaire qui est extrêmement
vieillissant séjour au carénage il ya
aussi 50 milliards d'euros pour la
construction des nouveaux réacteurs
donc la corde milliard c'est pour
combien de nouveaux réacteurs
aujourd'hui sont annoncés je peux je
sais pas où on parle de deux sets 2-6
enfin bon voilà donc on a pu tellement
des chiffres véritablement tête mais ce
qui est sûr c'est que madame disait on a
pris des mesures générales
gaieté de coeur mais non vous avez pris
à la fois des mesures générales là en
l'occurrence pour edf vous avez pris
beaucoup de mesures ciblées donc usine à
gaz quand on pense à la hausse du barème
kilométrique c'est une mesure ciblée
quand on pense à la au chèque inflation
ou chèque énergie oui ça ne concerne pas
tout le monde madame donc vous voyez
bien que vous mixez un petit peu les
deux mais finalement voilà c'est pas que
des mesures générales qui serait de
nature à ne pas être des usines à gaz
comme pour elle à des mesures ciblées
que vous avez néanmoins prise
aujourd'hui ce qu'il faut voir c'est que
edf ne pourra pas ou en tout cas
beaucoup plus difficilement mener un
certain nombre de grands projets
structurels vous avez fait référence le
grand carénage le nouveau nucléaire la
transition énergétique tous hélas un peu
et à combien les chiffres et la
politique nucléaire proposé par votre
candidat de l'ailé pécresse je n'ai pas
de chiffres et je ne sais même pas si
pour l'heure elle a mis sur la table de
véritables chiffres en matière de
politique nucléaire ce qui est sûr c'est
que la famille politique à laquelle
j'appartiens à une autre candidate est
fermement attaché a effectivement une
politique énergétique qui s'appuie en
grande partie sur le nucléaire qui
n'exclut pas les énergies renouvelables
mais qui s'appuient fortement sur
l'énergie nucléaire qui est une énergie
décarbonée et qui bien évidemment pose
aussi des questions sur la sécurité sur
la question des déchets mais dont on
voit combien elle est importante pour
notre pays ne serait ce qu'en matière de
souveraineté est donc aujourd'hui il est
important de pouvoir s'inscrire sur une
politique énergétique nucléaire sur le
long terme alors français c'est
intéressant parce que il ya plusieurs
voix notamment dans le camp des
écologistes qui disent que c'est cette
logique de maintien nucléaire c'est une
façon de ne pas s'engager dans la
sobriété en termes de consommation
d'électricité et d'énergie d'abord il
faut distinguer le parc qui existent et
la construction de nouveaux réacteurs le
parc existe il ya il n'y a pas de moyens
plus économique de produire des
kilowattheures que le parc nucléaire qui
existe donc largement amortis donc si
vous fermer fessenheim vous jeter de
l'argent par la fenêtre si vous décidez
que en 2025 il faut passer à 50% de
nucléaire à vous jeter de l'argent par
la fenêtre et savions que les centrales
nucléaires du parc elles vont fermer un
jour figurez vous qu'il n'ya pas besoin
de dire il faut les fermer à 40 à 35 à
53 ans de toute façon elles le sont
prolonger leur durée de vie quand même
et bien et il faut ça vous dit que ce
sont des milliards j'ai bien utilisé
voilà il faut prolonger leur durée de
vie jusqu'au moment où ça coûte
tellement cher de prolonger la durée de
vie qu'elles vont produire un
kilowattheure beaucoup plus cher que des
moyens que les investissements nouveaux
donc laissons faire l'autorité de sûreté
nucléaire qui va dire ah non non non là
il faut vraiment l'arrêter parce que les
conditions de sûreté ne sont pas
satisfaisantes on a une très bonne
notoriété de sûreté nucléaire qu'est
capable de dire ça et les sons
l'opérateur dire non je vais pas faire
ces travaux parce que les travaux vont
coûter plus cher et mais mon
kilowattheure mon mégawattheure et je
vais pas recouvré mes investissements
avec les prix pour les dix prochaines
années du mégawattheure donc laissons-le
opérateurs ou en tout cas voyons un
dialogue entre l'opérateur et l'autorité
de sûreté nucléaire pour savoir quand
est-ce qu'on ferme les réacteurs est pas
et pas la décision des pouvoirs publics
qui vont dire à louis voilà on fait 50%
en 2025 où on fait 50 % de heureusement
qu'on a reculé parce que donc maintenant
on fait 50 % en 2011 ceci dit c'est une
bonne idée de faire 50 % c'est à que mon
mon opposition elle est de marquer une
date c'est une bonne idée pourquoi parce
que c'est quand même un risque d'avoir
quand vous êtes quand votre énergie et
surtout produites par du parent seul
moyen est donc à des risques systémiques
s'il faut fermer dix réacteurs parce
qu'il ya un problème de sûreté la france
sera marque donc à son à 50% mais ne
mettons pas date en disant on va passer
à 50% en 2025 en 2035 et donc vous vous
dites pour bien comprendre si on veut
essayer de
de garder un prix de l'électricité
relativement bas ou en tout cas et
limiter la flambée il faut prolonger le
parc nucléaire le plus longtemps
possible le plus longtemps possible et
le plus longtemps possible ça veut dire
avec des conditions de sûreté
satisfaisante sur et ça veut dire que
l'opérateur va gagner plus d'argent en
rallongeant la durée de vie des
centrales prix que
par que de ne pas le faire alors tous
les candidats évidemment y vont de leurs
solutions écoutez deux candidats à
gauche l'écologiste jadot le communiste
roussaly veulent nationaliser
pour prendre le contrôle total d'edf
s'en remettre edf comme un établissement
public industriel et commercial
un epic soutenir l'industrie lutter pour
le pouvoir d'achat des français contre
la vie chère c'est proposer un mix
énergétique
s'appuyant sur du renouvelables et du
nucléaire
et par la nationalisation d'edf et
d'anne j
dominique estrosi sassone j'imagine que
vous n'avez pas favorable à la
nationalisation d'edf pourquoi non ça ne
vous étonnera pas je pense que c'est une
vision au mythique qui nous conduira
droit dans le mur je pense qu'il faut
effectivement réorganiser edf il y avait
un projet de réforme projet et recule on
a vu combien il était trop complexe et
finalement il n'a pas donné de résultat
ou en tout cas il n'est pas allé à sa
fin donc bien sûr il faut réorganiser
edf aujourd'hui je pensais en tout cas
c'est ce que défendent les républicains
c'est qu'il faut diviser scindé en deux
edf d'un côté un edf privé vendant
l'électricité
achetée comme d'autres en gros à un edf
public avec une société qui serait 100%
nationale et qui ne concernerait que
l'énergie nucléaire que la construction
de nouveaux réacteurs que la relance de
l'atome parce que il en va aussi de
notre souveraineté souveraineté et qui
assumerait cette mission de souveraineté
et ainsi je pense qu'on pourrait à la
fois donner une priorité
véritablement au nucléaire m aussi
combinez cela avec un investissement
public massif est libéralisée la
production bening pérol finalement c'est
effectivement un enjeu de souveraineté
là l'idée d'une nationalisation
partielle ou totale qu'est ce que vous
en pensez la nationalisation elle
impliquerait et la commission open où
nous inviterait à vendre d'ailleurs une
partie des activités pour être conforme
au droit au droit de la haute route en
partie au droit de la concurrence donc
il faut je ne nie pas que il ne faudra
pas peut-être un m'ont donné une
nationalisation temporaire comme on l'a
fait d'ailleurs pour certaines
entreprises publiques pour redonner la
capacité à edf justement à investir et
prendre le temps pendant une phase de
transition aussi de savoir quel avenir
on donne à edf justement sur ces
activités qu'on garde celle qu'on
préserve celle qu'on privatise
totalement je crois qu'il faut pas
totalement l'exclure je crois qu'il faut
pas être dogmatique sur sur le sujet en
revanche nationalisée à 100% et n'avoir
plus qu'un sdf public je n'y crois pas
et je ne crois pas que ce soit forcément
la solution pour l'avenir non plus
françois lévêque l'état possède déjà 84%
du capital si on regarde précisément ses
83 88 % suite on a des actionnaires
institutionnels et individuels à 14 77 %
les actionnaires salariés 1,32 et l'auto
détention
0,03 nationaliser edf qu'est ce que ça
changerait quoi concrètement que
nationaliser donc pourquoi nationalistes
s'étaient déjà été ma première réaction
quand j'ai entendu
jadot c'est pas une boutade le faut bien
les actionnaires privés aujourd'hui à
ils peuvent porter plainte parce que
voilà parce qu'en parce que il y une
mesure gouvernementale cdu hold up si
vous voulez on va leur faire perdre de
l'argent donc les actionnaires privés
peuvent porter plainte on a vu déjà que
la fermeture de fessenheim qui est
coûteuse qui fait perdre des recettes a
eu des faits bien et bien le
dédommagement a été très très faible
donc je pense pas que les actionnaires
la seule différence peut-être c'est que
les actionnaires privés peuvent essayer
de mobiliser
les aspects juridiques pour obtenir des
dédommagements
lorsque les pouvoirs publics lorsque
l'actionnaire public prend des mesures
qui leur sont défavorables si vous êtes
à 100% il y aurait plus cet effet là
mais si le seul c'est la seule
différence que je vois mathieu on est
dans l'ordre du symbole la folle
politique
jadot on n'est pas dépendant des
solutions très étonnante de la peur de
savoir la deûle et sur la politique qui
sont là où on les attend mais la
nationalisation c'est est ce que l'état
serait plus efficace à la tête d'un d'un
l'edf qu'il possède à 100% ou est-ce
qu'il est aussi opérationnel est aussi
efficace à la tête d'un le dfe il
possède à 84% moi je vois pas une énorme
différence ça c'est pas l'état enfin si
opérationnel est assez plutôt est ce que
l'état serait moins efficace et plus
opérationnel mais quand on parle de
l'avenir d'edf de toute façon l'état
sera là enfin je
reviens sur le jeu revient sur le ce que
disait eric zemmour tout à l'heure ce
qu'on a ce qu'on a diffusé on se levait
une autre façon l'etat sera là est-ce
qu'il ya pas un risque de non mais
l'état les l'existence de cette
entreprise publique
schizophrène c'est que l'état veut à la
fois une entreprise publique dont il se
sert comme levier pour maintenir du
pouvoir d'achat pour maintien de
l'emploi pour pour investir dans les
nouvelles technologies et puis l'état
aussi évidemment une vision ou en tout
cas des nécessités de vision de long
terme et et d'investissement donc l'état
oscille entre les deux selon les moments
selon les moments politiques selon les
moments économique donc l'actionnaire
public est plurielle en fait et donc est
ce que l'etat sera toujours là
je ne sais pas là on a en tout cas deux
représentantes 6 et emmanuel macron
l'etat sera toujours là si c'est valérie
pécresse oui l'etat sera toujours là je
pense bien évidemment et nous sommes
attachés à edf même si nous pensons
qu'il faut mener une réforme importante
et rien organiser le df tels que je pus
vous l'exprimer merci beaucoup merci à
tous d'avoir participé à ce débat
françois y avait que j'appelle le titre
de votre livre consacré au nucléaire
dans nucléaire au nov analyse économique
d' à paris et c'est publié aux éditions
dunod merci à toutes et à tous de votre
fidélité je vous donne rendez vous
évidemment demain pour un nouveau numéro
de sens public et